what's the role of simulation
in reinforcement learning and deep
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning
like how essential is it it's been
essential
for the breakthroughs so far for some
interesting breakthroughs
do you think it's a crutch that we rely
on
i mean again this connects to our off
policy uh discussion but
do you think we can ever get rid of
simulation or do you think simulation
will actually take over we'll create
more and more realistic simulations that
will allow us to uh
to solve actual real world problems like
transfer the models who learn simulation
through real world problems yeah
i think that simulation is a very
pragmatic tool that we can use to get a
lot of useful stuff to work right now
but i think that in the long run we will
need to build machines
that can learn from real data because
that's the only way that we'll get them
to improve perpetually
because if we can't have our machines
learn from real data if they have to
rely on simulated data
eventually the simulator becomes the
bottleneck in fact this is a general
thing if your machine
has any bottleneck that is built by
humans
and that doesn't improve from data it
will eventually be the thing that holds
it back
and if you're entirely aligned on your
simulator that'll be the bottleneck if
you're entirely
reliant on a manually designed
controller that's going to be the
bottleneck
so simulation is very useful it's very
pragmatic
but it's not a substitute for being able
to utilize
real experience and this is by the way
this is something that i think is
quite uh relevant now especially in the
context of some of the things we've
discussed because
some of these uh kind of scaffolding
issues that i mentioned things like the
broken dishes
and the unknown reward functions like
these are not problems that you would
ever stumble on
when working in a purely simulated kind
of environment but they become very
apparent when we try to actually run
these things
in the real world to throw a brief
wrench into our discussion let me ask do
you think we're living in a simulation
oh i have no idea
do you think that's a useful thing to
even think about about the
the the the fundamental physics nature
of reality
uh or another perspective the reason i
think the simulation
hypothesis is interesting is it's to
think about
how difficult is it to create sort of a
virtual reality game
type situation that will be sufficiently
convincing to us humans
or sufficiently enjoyable that would we
wouldn't want to leave
that's actually a practical engineering
challenge
and i i personally really enjoy virtual
reality but it's quite
far away but i kind of think about what
would it take for me to want to spend
more time in virtual reality versus the
real world
and that's a that's a sort of a nice
clean
question because at that point
we've reached if i want to live in a
virtual reality that means we're just a
few years away where a majority the
population lives in a virtual reality
and that's how we create the simulation
right you don't need to actually
simulate the
you know the quantum gravity and just
every
aspect of the of the universe and that's
a re
that's an interesting question for
reinforcement learning too is if we want
to make sufficiently realistic
simulations that may
it it blend the difference between sort
of the real world and the simulation
thereby just other some of the things
we've been talking about
kind of the problems go away if we can
create actually interesting rich
simulations
it's an interesting question and it
actually i think your question
casts your previous question to in a
very interesting light
because in some ways asking whether we
can
um well the more prac the more kind of
practical
version is like you know can we build
simulators that are good enough to train
essentially ai systems that will work in
the world
and it's kind of interesting to think
about this about what this implies if
true
it kind of implies that it's easier to
create the universe than it is to create
a brain
and that seems like put this way it
seems kind of weird
the aspect of the simulation most
interesting to me
is the simulation of other humans
that seems to be
a complexity that makes the robotics
problem
harder now i don't know if every
robotics person
agrees with that notion just as a quick
aside what are your
thoughts about when the human enters the
picture of the robotics problem
how does that change the reinforcement
learning problem the the learning
problem in general
yeah i think that's a it's a kind of a
complex question and
i guess my hope for a while had been
that if we build
these robotic learning systems that that
are multi-task that utilize lots of
prior data
and that learn from their own experience
the bit where they have to interact with
people
will be perhaps handled in much the same
way as all the other bits
so if they have prior experience of
interacting with people and they can
learn from their own experience of
interacting with people for this new
task
maybe that will be enough um now of
course there
if it's not enough there are many other
things we can do and there's quite a bit
of research in that in that area
but i think it's worth a shot to see
whether the
uh the the multi-agent interaction the
the ability to understand
that other uh beings in the world have
their own goals and tensions and
thoughts and so on
whether that kind of understanding can
emerge
automatically from simply learning to do
things
with and maximize utility that
information arises from the data
you